it's on because you're an editor do you
think that having a sizzle reel as part
of most of the ideas that you come up
with has been sort of your core way of
getting people attached or can you just
talk about that process
yeah I mean I think I think it's it's
essential as a matter of fact at this
point like did the moment I have like a
kernel of an idea I immediately start
thinking of what's the sizzle for this
and oftentimes I have this already for
the script long before the script is
ever done as a matter of fact I have
sizzles for scripts that we never
finished oh wow yeah it's just you know
people reading scripts everyone will
imagine it completely differently I mean
there's people who read danger one the
same draft but they didn't picture it as
a funny movie but the movie we made is
an action comedy you know but
that same script could have been made as
a very straightforward serious film and
I'm sure a lot of people read it that
way but to be able to then send along a
sizzle reel a three-minute short that
says this is the tone so when you read
the script imagine it like this you know
and you have actors in there so they
stay there's phases that they can put on
these characters when they read them and
again the script could also the film you
make could look a million different ways
you know it could be it could look the
way danger one does now you know very
energetic and vibrant and colorful or it
could have been a lot more grounded and
have more of a you know a documentary
isn't the right word but more of a yeah
more of a grounded look you know very
muted but again no one knows that until
you and you can describe these things
but then again you're using words like
vibrant can mean a million different
things so it's just best to like here
just check this out if there's a look
this is what the movies gonna be like
and honestly I think danger one and
that's how we got it made because when
the the financier is what they responded
to yes was the idea because they weren't
looking for something that kind of takes
place in one night and like but
characters that are starting to deal
with a this big moral dilemma but they
saw the sizzle and their reaction was
like oh this looks like pain and gain
and so they said and that's how that's
that's that's what made them pull the
trigger also it just shows especially if
you haven't done a movie before it shows
that you can shoot something you know
because you're like you can be like look
if I know I haven't made a movie but I
just did this and it's a short film and
even if it's a partial script o matic
where you're borrowing some stuff if you
make some of these elements yourself it
just it shows that you know how to tell
a story as a matter of fact even if it's
a full script o matic and you're just
editing stuff together
it also shows such a can tell a story
because you knew what you what you
needed to look for when you were you
know assembling these shots
you just didn't shoot him yourself it
just shows that you know a little
something about how to
put a piece together that's not on the
page but an actual visual thing and
danger one is your first feature but
you've edited so much content that I'm
sure you're probably or I'm just
assuming I shouldn't assume but do it
that it was fairly easy or no well if
the last so since we since I finished
post on danger one I've put together two
new sizzle reel I didn't shoot those
though so they're just script oh Maddox
dose I can now do and like a week you
know just because it's I've everything
I've sort of a pipeline for these things
now it's just a matter of finding the
right footage but yeah it can be done in
a week the sizzle for danger one since
it didn't use any borrowed footage it
was all shot I mean that's a legit
production then it's we had to I mean
yeah that took probably like two months
of prep because you're casting your
location scouting you know you're trying
not to spend a lot of money but you're
you're putting together a full-blown
production I mean there's had a full
crew we had you know trucks we had yeah
I mean it was like a real short film
production so that's going to take a
little longer but that's where it comes
in having a editing you know during the
day allows you to kind of finance that
stuff I'm just not putting that money in
the bank you know it's you're just
reinvesting it but so yeah that probably
overall with post and everything cuz we
have to do ADR on it got color time that
probably took like four months until it
was done but then again you're not
wasting time because the scripts still
being written
simultaneously would you be able to tell
us how much it cost to produce the whole
god yeah they got more and more
expensive when you when you're straight
out of school everyone so II know one
has a job you know everyone's so eager
to like be on a set and like make stuff
so the very first sizzle the one for
that teens conspiracy thriller with
Aimee Teegarden
we had like a two-day shoot we had a
pretty decent cast we had a full crew
that I was able to do for I think $2,000
yeah I know I
that was still the case danger one this
is will happen a few years later at that
point everyone has really good jobs you
know people are shooting their their
crewing on television shows - making a
lot of money so it's like for them to
come out take time off and be on my set
you have to pay him something so the the
the sizzle for danger one was just a
one-day shoot with a smaller cast but it
it was eventually like ten thousand
dollars and was not were you in Napa
when you were filming the team no no
we're just mad she dead okay the danger
one sister we actually also shot Oh we
shot that not in Vernon but in in South
LA that's right but after that one day
once you know you once you're paying
real real rates it's gonna add up add up
quickly so the sizzle reels are
obviously cheaper that's why those are
attractive and I think now that I've
made a film I don't have to prove so
much that I know how to work behind a
camera it's easier for me to just do a
sizzle because I could just be like yeah
guys I made a movie you check that one
out but before you have a movie no one
knows that you can do it so yeah I think
like it was it was $10,000 well
well-spent
but you're not paying for editing right
because you're editing that's right ah
okay so I would imagine that cuts the
price down a lot yeah that's great
anything everyone else how long are
these sizzle reel at the end result of
the sizzle reel um if it's just a ripple
Matic I kind of stick to I mean I make
these things really does play like an
actual trailer so they're they're the
length of a trailer so they're a minute
and 40 the thing is like people's
attention span in this town especially
if they're producers or executives is
like that so if it's long they're just
gonna tune out so you might you want to
cut to the chase what quick you want to
you know get to selling your hook within
the first like 10 15 seconds but the
sizzle for danger one that was long so
that was I think a little over three
minutes only because it has a short form
if Feltham played more like a short film
but in hindsight
there's probably a whole bunch of people
that did see that and tuned out just
because they don't have time if I was
shooting one of these again I'd make it
shorter and usually when I'm now that
when I make sizzle reels and I work with
producers on them their note usually is
like yeah just trim out like ten seconds
you know it's like you want to make
these things short so what would your
advice be to a first-time filmmaker on
making a sizzle reel they want to try it
they want to show people that they're
serious they want to show people their
talent they have the original cast that
they plan to use attached what are some
of your tips
why don't know if you want to have your
cast attached and if because well it
depends on the budget I guess but if
you're like with danger one where the
movie had you know our budget wasn't
high but it did cost you know some you
don't want to come in with people
attached because the people financing
the movie and the producers they'll have
their own ideas okay as a matter of fact
even even in terms of crew and producers
like on danger one none of my regular
guys were working on this movie because
the crew was was brought in by the
producers so you're really well you you
really just kind of want to sell the
story and yourself but no I mean that
honestly the biggest thing is like I
said just but I mean structure these
things the way you would a movie like
you don't want your movie the story in
your movie to get started at the 1 hour
mark you know they say you have to
incite an incident happen at 20 minutes
so kind of your trailer minute and 40
seconds structure it like that just get
to the hook quick so people don't turn
it off because they have a million other
things to do and yeah and I think I mean
missiles that I and that's just again
because I'm a bit OCD and a
perfectionist like they like we made
them look like polished I mean we went
in and really made sure that they said
they sound exactly like a real trailer
sometimes I even had a
a composer friend of mine composed music
for them you know we some of them we
mixed professionally some of them we
didn't personally this is this is just
calling in favors people that I met in
in film school color time time
professional it's just so people are
like wow this looks good I want to I
want to make a film that looks exactly
like that to be honest like the sizzle
reel for danger one looks as good as to
film itself yeah so you think the
difference between the $2,000 sizzle
reel that you did for the the Napa
Valley teen horror one and in danger one
is because you were using people that
weren't students that weren't just out
of school that we're looking for credit
or whatever that was the main difference
in the price um yeah it was just it's
basically how it comes down to how far
removed are you from film school because
a lot of people that worked on that
sizzle also worked on the danger one
sizzle but it was just four years later
in their careers and you know they've
got a family to feed and and rent to pay
so it's like yeah it'll be easier right
out of school but then also like four
years when most of us are making more
money then you know like then the higher
budget doesn't hurt quite as much when I
did the $2,000 at sizzle reel that was a
lot you know cuz I was young and I
didn't make a lot of money so it's not
it costing later down the road is
slightly offset by the fact that you are
also deeper into your career making more
and you're a little ape you're more able
to actually finance some of this stuff
even on like when it comes to like a
lists directors on big movies he always
always hear about like how they shoot
sizzles I know that um which movie was
this oh it was for the they were gonna
do a daredevil remake a couple years ago
and I think the director of one of the
Twilight movies so that's a list right I
mean he's famous and makes a lot of
shoots like Game of Thrones
I think he spent like what was that like
sixty thousand dollars on a sizzle that
he shot just to show what his vision is
so a lot of people are doing that just
to show Studios and producers what they
can do and I guess I'd these things if
you want to do it right it's gonna
it can add up what's the biggest aside
from being your own editor which I know
saves a lot and gives you a lot more
creative control what are some other
things that could save some of money to
make a sizzle reel um well I mean well
yes I mean it's basically it's working
with you know and that's where your if
you went to film school or you've met
people in the industry if you worked in
the industry or just your friends but
yeah I mean the once there's not a lot
of places at some point where you where
you can save cuz things just cost as
much as they do in this town
they know I'm trying to think well and I
guess as an editor I mean I do my own
sound because in especially in reality
TV you kind of have to do your own sound
you don't do in scripted you you sort of
make your own music
we don't make about you you're given a
music libraries and you're cutting music
you know sort of scoring with the
elements that you're given so I'm not
just editing picture as an editor you
don't just add a picture but you also
have a bit of a you know how to deal
with sound yeah but I don't know I don't
know this I wish it could be done
cheaper for myself too once your sizzle
reel is final and you have it where you
want it what is then your approach to
getting it out there to getting managers
and agents to see it well back before I
had all that it was really just I would
just send it to my friends from from
film school you know because everyone
was at a certain stage in their careers
and had made their own contacts in the
industry and in film school you kinda
you know you kind of bond in the
trenches when you're shooting stuff
together so it's like you want to help
one another out so at that point yeah
we'll just send it out to two friends
from film school
once you have managers they will start
sending it out because they can reach
past you know the gatekeepers at
production companies
and and and studios and stuff but even
at that point I would still have my
friends send it out because they have
producer friends and stuff you want it
as many people as possible to see it
because people also start talking about
it you know like when when the
conspiracy thriller when that sizzle
went out I was getting emails from
people at agencies because they had seen
it I had no idea how it how it popped up
in those offices but it did because like
if something's good you know it'll
travel and now that I've been doing this
for 10 years
I mean even now I'm it's these things go
to friends of theirs different producers
I work with so like they send it out you
know I don't think that's ever gonna
change I feel like I'm sending it to the
same people every time what if someone
doesn't what if they didn't go to
college and they still have a vision
they're making a film how could they get
it out there and they don't have a huge
network of friends if you people that
live in LA for people that live in LA
it's probably a little easier because
inevitably you are gonna meet people
that work in the industry even if you
didn't go to film school if you live
elsewhere I honestly don't know I mean
just because I've never lived elsewhere
outside of LA I don't know how do well I
mean I guess it's easier now because you
there's social media you can put it on
YouTube I mean there's you know you read
about stories of people getting there
you know they shot a trailer somewhere
and then someone in LA saw it I think
the what's-his-name the director who did
the latest spider-man movie he did he
did cop car but before cop car he did a
movie called I think was clown was a
horror film that from started
because and he's not from LA he shot I
think so yes so he he just shot a fake
trailer and somehow for for a clown
horror movie and somehow Eli Roth saw
that and then executive produced the
feature film for that so and I don't
know how Roth saw it but I mean that's
a--that's something that just kind of
went
went viral you know I don't know how you
make something go viral but if it's if
it's good you know I guess that just
happens that's the million dollar
question yeah but I mean I think it's
easier now than it was 10 years ago just
because the world's become so small you
know if you put it out there someone
will see it
you